- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy,
happy international women's day.
And in honor of international women's day,
we have a special guest,
someone who I know quite well,
Khan Academy's Chief
People Officer Regina Ross.
We're going to talk about
her journey and careers
and developing careers
as a woman, or as anyone.
But before we jump into that conversation,
I'll give my standard
announcement, first of all,
a reminder that we are a not
for profit at Khan Academy.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
Donations of all size
make a huge difference.
Also wanna give a special
shout out to many folks
who support Khan Academy,
especially when the pandemic hit.
And I think we're finally
surfacing from it,
but allowed us to really
do things like homeroom
and provide support for almost three X
the users that we were
seeing when the pandemic hit
so special thanks to AT&T General Motors
and Fastly for that.
And all of our other supporters
who really keep Khan Academy
going as a not for profit.
And last but not least,
a reminder that there's a podcast version
of this live stream available
wherever you get your podcast,
Homeroom With Sal, the podcast.
And now with that,
I'm excited to introduce
you to Regina Ross,
Khan Academy's Chief
People Officer, hey Regina.
- Hi Sal, I'm glad to be here.
- So before we jump into
questions, I'll remind everyone
whether you're watching
on a YouTube, Facebook,
or I believe we're actually
live streaming on LinkedIn
today, post your questions,
our team members are gonna
help surface it to me
so that I can get to Regina,
topic is about leadership,
about managing organizations,
et cetera, et cetera.
But Regina,
I always like to start pretty
early in people's journey.
If you could tell us a little bit about
what you were like as a
kid, where did you grow up?
Did you think you would be a
Chief People Officer one day?
Did you even know what that is?
Tell us a little bit
about yourself as a child.
- Very interesting question.
So I loved and thrived
in the academic setting.
I was a nerd, a smart kid, loved school.
My father was in the military,
so we did travel a bit.
But then we landed in at
home in Montgomery, Alabama,
and that's where I went to
school, graduated there.
I was part of the gifted program
throughout elementary school
and I loved math and science.
And so this really led to
my journey into engineering.
Did you know, you knew I
was an engineer, right?
- That's one of the reasons why,
one of the many reasons we
definitely connected on that.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I love to travel.
And let me just tell you the story,
so I was really adept at math and science
and I had a high school chemistry teacher
who says, hey, Regina,
you should attend this
minority introduction
to engineering program, MIGHT program.
It was a two week introductory
program at Auburn University.
And that really opened my eyes
to the world of engineering
because I really didn't
know what an engineer was.
So I was able to who explore
different disciplines of engineering,
and I landed on industrial engineering
because I loved the intersection
of people and processes.
So I attended Auburn
University in Alabama.
Didn't want to go too far away from home,
but just far enough away.
Graduated Summa, cum laude
and started my engineering career.
And Sal, I'll tell you, even
though I did engineering,
continuous process improvement,
mostly in manufacturing,
I did transition into
operations, leadership,
sales leadership,
you know, I was a regional
logistics manager.
I have always had a passion
for helping people develop.
And maybe it's because of the
way that my chemistry teacher
took an interest in me, and
like, hey, you can do more.
So that's been my passion
for employee engagement,
leadership development.
And I was eventually
tapped on the shoulder.
I was an operations senior
leader at a big box retailer.
And they're like, hey, Regina,
we want you to step into HR.
And so the cause of my
culture focus leadership,
I took the role and I
fell in love with HR.
I say that I crossed over to the dark side
and I haven't looked back.
And the thing about HR that I love Sal
is it really enabled me to
focus on connecting talent
and culture to the business outcomes.
One thing you didn't know is
when I was a junior in college
pursuing my engineering degree,
I wanted to shift majors.
Like I wanna do something to help people.
I was thinking of being in
ministry or being a nun,
something.
And my mom's like, no,
you're gonna finish
your engineering degree.
And so it was me stepping into
HR years later, like, okay,
I get it, I'm able to help people,
I'm able to drive my business outcomes.
And just seeing that
connecting of my passion
and my purpose, I love what I do.
- There's a bunch of really
interesting threads there.
And just to connect the
dots, 'cause obviously
there's a lot of young
people watching this,
probably young men and
women watching this,
probably trying to figure out,
okay, is this an interesting path for me.
How do you navigate this?
I know in high school, college,
everyone has a lot of angst,
so like, what am I gonna do with my life?
And it sounds like you found this passion
for math and science fairly early on.
I think it helped that you had
other people believe in you.
I definitely resonate with
that part of your journey
and then industrial engineering,
which I don't think a lot of people know,
but to your point, it's kind of like,
how do you optimize a factory?
You click on a button on
Amazon, now how does that,
how do they figure out how to put
the right thing in the right package
and get it to the right
place, process design.
So it's pretty broad, a set of things.
And then you went into what
you kind of called operations,
but that would be more of like,
it still is process for
people in a lot of ways.
- It is.
Mm-hmm.
- And then you went
into HR, human resources
and I think this is something,
I think I was a naive
initially when I was coming
straight outta college,
I'm like, okay, I'm gonna go
work for a software company,
and that means that a software company
does nothing but write software.
What do all these other people do?
And I've now realized when
you have an organization,
human resources, the
people function, it's core,
'cause it's all about
people doing everything.
So.
- Absolutely.
- How do you think about people operations
or human resources
to someone who was naive
like me in my early 20s?
- You know what, that's what it is.
And I was so fortunate Sal,
when I started at a particular company,
I won't say the name, but I
started as an operations leader.
So this is when I'm leaving
my engineering career,
going into operations leadership
at a distribution organization.
And as a senior leader, I
had to do some onboarding,
and one of the courses was
thinking like an HR manager,
like what?
I'm not an HR person,
but the way that they
put it together is that,
you're not just leading or
managing your business processes,
you're leading and
managing a team of people
who make it happen.
And I some great mentors who taught me,
Regina, if you take care of the team,
they will take care of the business
and take care of the client.
And so this is why
I think I had this culture
focused leadership mindset
and approach that, yeah,
I'm an operations leader,
I'm an engineering leader,
but at the end of the day,
it's taking care of the people
and Sal, when I stepped into
my first full-time HR leader role,
the dots really connected.
And I saw that potential of
really focusing full-time
on helping the culture
and the people deliver on
the business priorities.
And I will tell you the Khan
Academy job posting that I saw,
it really resonated with me.
And so I didn't have a
background in nonprofit,
I didn't have a background
in the educational industry.
So when I saw the job posting,
I'm like, I don't know
if I'm going to be a fit,
but there was something in
that that kept pulling at me.
And I'm just gonna read this verbiage
that was from the job description,
it said that this role
was to help foster a
high performance culture
and a great place to work
that enables employees
to deliver their best work
towards attaining Khan Academy's mission
while fulfilling their
personal aspirations
and career ambitions.
Drop the mic.
That was it for me, I was sold.
(chuckles)
- No, that's funny.
- That's what I'm doing.
That's why I'm so excited to be here.
And it's not, so I love Khan
Academy. I love what we do.
And my kids, I use Khan
Academy with my kids
because even though I'm an engineer,
they struggle with math and science.
I'm like, go figure.
But I know of the benefit and
the beauty of this product
and what we do.
And when I saw this, like the mission,
and then me in my role
in people operations,
and actually this
statement that I just read,
this is now our people operations
team missions statement,
about really fostering that
high performance culture,
a great place to work, that
really does enable employees
to deliver their best work.
And so I'm just excited to be here.
I love what I do, I love Khan Academy.
- No, I think there's a
little bit of lesson in there,
which is, one, your journey
already took a couple of turns.
And even in that last stage,
before you came to Khan Academy,
there was a little part of you said,
well, I've never worked
at a non-for-profit,
I wasn't in education.
- Yeah.
- But this thing really resonated me.
So you were able to kind of
not feel imposter syndrome
and say, I'm gonna try it.
- Mm-hmm.
- And as we all know, we
were excited to hire you,
but that reminds me of, I
could have never guessed
that I would've been
in this role either.
- Mm-hmm.
- I remember in business school,
business school I went to,
they didn't really fail anyone,
but if they did fail someone,
they give one twos and threes in a class.
And the only class that I got a three in
was called social
entrepreneurship, because.
- No way.
- I was so cynical about the
not for profit sector.
- Wow.
- Back then.
And fate, destiny, whatever,
irony would have it,
that this is, I plan on doing
this the rest of my life
now.
- Mm-hmm.
- So I think everyone's life
takes these twists and turns.
I am curious,
and I always like to get into
the head every now and then,
or pretty commonly, I
meet people, teenagers,
or people early in their careers,
and there's so much uncertainty
of what they wanna do
with their life.
- Mm-hmm.
If you could go back in time
or at least to send a message back in time
to 20 year old Regina
or 30 year old Regina,
what would you tell them?
- Yes.
And I'm glad you asked that question
because I have spoken to like my kids,
and other young people that I'm mentoring
and trying to help.
So my tips, one would be to
try different experiences
and versus just sticking
with only one thing
and only doing what you know well.
So I've been in engineering,
I've been in operations leadership,
I've been in transportation,
I've done sales leadership.
Like I don't like that, I don't
wanna do a sales leadership.
But it helped me to
understand what I liked
and what I didn't like,
what I was good at, what I wasn't good at.
The second thing I would say is build
and leverage a really
strong support network.
I call it a personal board of directors.
So you have mentors, sponsors, advisors.
My career, I wouldn't be where I am
were it not for like my chemistry teacher,
who I'm still in touch with.
You know, people who taught
me strategic planning,
people who taught me the
unwritten rules of the road
in every corporation that I've been at.
And so leverage that support network.
One thing specifically for women
is that we tend to
build the relationships,
but according to "How Women
Rise" by Sally Helgesen
is that we don't leverage those.
We think it's not good for us
to reach out and ask for help.
So we've gotta build our
network, leverage the network.
I would say another tip
or lesson learned throughout my career
is excel at the right things.
So I can't be perfect at everything.
I know that I'm good at project
management and some things,
I'm not so good at maybe email management.
And so it's about excelling
at the right things,
focus on what matters most.
So particularly when you
go into an organization,
you're building your career,
find out what's really important.
I've seen other women and I
myself have fallen into the trap
of sometimes just being heads down
and just trying to get a lot of work done.
And you burn the candle at both ends,
and you're trying to do a lot of work,
but you're not focusing on
what really matters the most.
Another tip is know your worth
and advocate for yourself.
This is something specifically for women
and there's a lot of studies,
but one in particular is
"Women in the Workplace
by McKinsey and LeanIn
where there's just a gap, right?
And this is why we're celebrating
on international women's
day, #breakthebias.
So know your worth, advocate for yourself.
Typically men will negotiate
when it comes to salary time
or for promotions and women, we don't.
And so it's just really
important to make sure that
you know what it is that you want,
that you advocate for yourself,
you prepare yourself for that journey
and for those greater things.
And this one Sal is so
important, I think this last one
is really defining
success on your own terms
versus just avoid the comparison trap
because my journey
may be very different than
someone else's journey,
and that's okay.
I have taken a lot of twist
and turns in my career.
And in my development,
I wasn't really focused
on chasing the title
or the promotion or making this move here,
it was about me and my experiences,
my total quality of life.
And so I'm thankful and
grateful for where I landed,
but I tell you, there are
times where I look to the left
and look to the right, like,
oh, I should be at this level by now,
or this person is doing that.
And I just really have to,
hey, let me define success for myself.
One thing I would say for
younger people is that they think
they've gotta have it
all mapped out early on.
And you really don't.
My kids struggled with this,
they were stressed out
because maybe as a junior in high school,
they didn't know exactly
what colleges they were gonna go to
and what they wanted to major in,
this is a tool that I found
maybe five or six years ago,
but it's a Japanese concept called Ikigai,
a Japanese term that
means reason for being,
and I wish I had this years ago,
but what it does in this Ikigai,
it's like a Venn diagram
where you are looking to
find that intersection
between what you love doing,
what the world needs,
what you're good it at,
and then what you can be paid for.
And so when you find that intersection,
that's that sweet spot or that Ikigai
your reason for being where like,
okay, I'm doing what I love,
I'm doing what I can be paid for,
you know, because some people
want to do a certain career,
but then they can't make a living at it.
And so if you can find that
sweet spot, you are golden.
Even if you can't find
that sweet spot in one job,
and this will be the
last thing I'll say Sal,
and turn it back over to you,
one thing I learned
from one of my managers
when I was a young engineer,
was Regina, you may not find
everything that you need
and get everything you
need out of this job.
So make sure that you have
other outlets for your talents,
for your interest, for your passions.
And this is where you
get into volunteering
or you do some things on the
side that fuel your passion
so that you're not getting frustrated
because you expect to get
everything out of that one job
or out of that first job.
and then you realize that
you're not getting
everything that you want.
So those would be my lessons
to the younger Regina.
I wish I would've known these
things years and years ago.
- I love it.
And I mean, just to summarize it,
'cause I think you could write
a book about this Regina,
personal board of directors,
(chuckles)
but don't just have 'em, leverage 'em.
- Yes.
- Advocate for yourself.
I do have a follow-up question about that
'cause I think that's an interesting thing
for a lot of folks, men and
women, but to your point,
it might be even a bigger
tension for some women,
but advocate for yourselves,
do things sustainably so
you don't burn both ends.
- Mm-hmm.
- Find your own swim lane.
That's when I strongly strongly believe,
and I wasn't really happy.
- Mm-hmm.
- On my career side until I had my own,
now I have my own swim lane.
I wasn't a very competitive
swim lane before
as a hedge fund analyst.
And no matter how much you succeed there,
when you define yourself by
comparison in that swim lane,
you're just never going to be never going
to be happy.
- That's right.
- So I love that swim lane.
And that last piece is,
I often give a version of
that to a lot of young people
is just, yeah,
make sure you always have
room for your passions.
No one job.
- Mm-hmm.
- Is going to be able to
check all of the boxes.
- That's right.
And so you're kind of overloading it
and then making it unsustainable
if you project everything.
- That's right.
Or you project everything onto it.
Well, one question,
you know, this is something
that I've struggled with
in my own career.
And you mentioned this
especially important
for a lot of young women is
to advocate for yourself.
And it's often hard when
you're in the moment to say,
how hard do I advocate for myself?
How hardball do I play?
- Mm-hmm.
Because.
- Yeah.
- There is a point where
people play too hardball.
(chuckles)
People say,
I'm sorry.
- Mm-hmm.
- You know, like,
and I've often seen this
even at Khan Academy,
like at Khan Academy as you know,
we take great pains that we say,
look, if someone's going to
be doing a job at a certain level,
this is what we're going to pay them.
And we have gotten.
- Mm-hmm.
- In the situation where someone's told us
their comp expectation is X,
and we're like, well, this job,
we're gonna pay you more.
(chuckles)
- Mm-hmm.
- So it's, we're not negotiating,
we're gonna try to pay everyone with fair
'cause even though
you could probably get
away in the short term
with paying someone less
if they thought that that's
what they were worth,
at some point, they're
gonna ask their friends,
they're gonna realize.
- Mm-hmm.
- That they were being
uncompensated.
- That's right.
And even the people who
are gonna be paid more
for that same job are like,
wait, this isn't a fair place.
Maybe I'm also getting
taken advantage somehow.
- Mm-hmm.
- So as an organization,
it's I think super makes sense to pay,
if people are doing the same
level, same performance,
same job, pay them the same
and be transparent about it.
But sometimes we have had
situations where people are like,
well, I need negotiate harder.
And we're trying to be very
transparent saying, no,
we literally give the same pay.
So we don't wanna be
based on negotiations.
So what advice do you have
to someone where it's like,
they wanna negotiate,
they wanna make sure they're
not taking advantage of,
which I completely agree.
- Mm-hmm.
- But also there could be situations where
it might be less productive?
- Yeah, I would say one, do your research.
So be well informed because
you may be asking for
a number that's just really unrealistic.
So, do your research, be informed.
And then know for yourself,
like, what is the non-negotiable,
what are you willing to?
And because that puts you
in the power of choice,
so you're not like, oh,
they only gave me this
and I had to accept this.
And I coach a lot of young women,
like, no, you're not
having to accept this.
You need to make a choice,
are you choosing to
accept it or are you not?
And so, and maybe you want this
number in your bare minimum,
it's like, you know what?
I think I could be satisfied here.
Then you make that decision of
I'm gonna be satisfied here,
or I'm gonna push for here,
and if I don't get this level,
then I'm willing to walk.
But you gotta have that internal dialogue
and be very clear about
what your limits are,
what your non-negotiables are
and stand in that power of choice
so you're not feeling
like they did this to me,
or they made me, like no,
that, no, you have a choice.
You always have a choice,
it's either you accept it or you don't.
Right.
- Yeah, no, it's really powerful.
I think throughout life,
whether it's negotiating comp,
but just everything in life,
I still find this tension
of how much do I advocate?
- Mm-hmm.
- Versus how much do I accept?
Or it is hard tension,
but I think being informed
is the right thing,
ask as many questions,
- Absolutely.
- Zero in and then know
what you really want,
know what you
really wanna deserve.
- That's right.
- Don't go into something.
if you're feeling kind of
bad about it on day one.
- Exactly.
- Like,
I think I'm underselling myself.
That's not gonna.
- Mm-hmm.
It's not.
- Set anyone up for success.
And I'll see on the organizational side.
- Mm-hmm.
- This is what we try to do.
And Regina,
you and I have a lot of
conversations about this,
how do we make
- mm-hmm.
- Comp more transparent
so we can give people.
- That's right.
- The confidence.
'Cause the worst thing you
want is to be an organization
or an environment where
you're wondering all the time.
- Mm-hmm.
- Of like.
- Yeah.
- Well, was this right.
- Am I being taken advantage of?
That's right.
Yeah.
- Exactly.
- And you wanna look at the total picture
of not just your base salary,
but your overall rewards,
you know, your time off, your
benefits, the quality of life,
the type of environment.
I have been many environment Sal
where we describe it as
the golden handcuffs.
Well, yeah, I'm getting a big salary,
a lot of stock and all that,
but it's a toxic environment.
And so you gotta look at success for you
in terms of like total
rewards, life experience,
quality of life, all of that,
and make the right decision for you.
- Oh, makes a ton of sense.
Well, we have some
questions going on here.
So I think this is a question
that a lot of people are wondering,
this is from Stephanie on social media,
with the pandemic having
gone on two years now,
what advice would you give to people
who are feeling burned out in
their job, career, et cetera?
- Yeah.
I really like Sal, thank you,
Stephanie for that question,
this whole Ikigai exercise,
like really taking that
time to be introspective
of what do I really want?
What am I passionate about?
What do I feel my purpose is?
Am I in a space where I can achieve that?
And if not, then evaluate, do
I need to make some changes?
Sometimes it may need to be a job shift,
sometimes it may need to
be putting some boundaries
in your personal life.
But, and we just don't even know.
We think this year is gonna
be a great year and we see,
still just more emotional trauma
that we're all having to deal with,
like evaluate what you need
and then determine what steps
actionably that you can
take to get what you need,
whether it's boundaries,
whether it's getting additional help,
whether it's doing something
that feeds your passion in volunteering,
because the answer may look
very different from you,
Stephanie than someone else.
- That's great advice.
And Regina, these homerooms,
especially when I talk to
really interesting guests
like you go way faster than I ever.
- I know.
- Expected.
But we're already running low on time,
but maybe just, if you could
kind of take us out with,
you heard Stephanie's question,
I think at all stages of people's careers,
there's this like.
- Mm-hmm.
- Am I doing the right thing?
Yes, all jobs have certain things that
you're not super pumped about,
but it has other things that are good.
How have you navigated it?
When do you know it's time to switch
versus time to just perceive.
- Hmm.
- What you're doing differently
or try to tweak what
you're doing within the job
or any other advice.
- Hmm.
- That you have for young
professionals or women everywhere?
- Yeah.
One, so couple of things,
one is have your own like
personal mission statement.
This is something that I learned
from "7 Habits of Highly
Effective People",
like have my own personal
mission statement
and then continually evaluate, where am I?
Am I attracting towards that?
Or am I not.
Is the job that I'm doing,
the role that I'm serving,
the way that I'm living,
is it in alignment with
that mission statement?
Am I moving towards my
purpose or am I not?
Sometimes we have detours.
And I just say, evaluate
the pluses and the deltas
and in your current
situation, do the pluses,
outweigh the deltas, all
right, or vice versa,
if the deltas or the
negatives outweigh the pluses,
then it may be time for a change.
And you are the only person
who can determine that.
There's a great person, Dr. Kim says,
if you always do what you've always done,
then you'll always get
what you've always got,
and only you can determine
if that is enough.
So this is what I would leave you with,
evaluate where you're going, is it enough?
And if it's, not make a change.
- I love that.
If you could send me that quote.
It's obviously.
- I will.
- Such a obviously true quote,
but something about the
phrasing that is so,
it's very poignant.
Well, Regina, thank you so
much for taking the time out.
I think as everyone can
tell, I feel blessed
and Khan Academy is blessed
to have you as our Chief People Officer.
And I look forward to going
on this journey together,
both helping support
the team at Khan Academy
in our journey to hopefully support
10s or 100s of millions of
people around the world,
but also be able to do things like this
and share your wisdom with
so many other people on the planet.
- Thank you Sal.
- Thanks (indistinct).
- I'm so glad to be here.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining.
I know I haven't been doing
these homerooms too frequently,
I'll try to do a few more frequently.
It's no longer the Daily Homeroom,
definitely when we started
during the pandemic,
but I hope you got as
inspired as I did from Regina.
And I gotta say, as someone
I work very closely with her
on a day to day basis,
I've already learned so, so much from her.
And this is one of the
best things about my job,
getting to work with Regina
and people like Regina
and how we can then empower others.
So with that, see you later, onward.
(electrical swoosh)